bienvenue au paradis
recouvert de 2 jean de poussière c'est
pas le travail qui me fait peur on est
là pour ça non pas en tant que
psychothérapeute
je t'assure bien connu les enfants sont
perturbées
tu peux me dire comment bkis et noyon à
cette question c'était écrit qu elle
revient dreamcatcher attrape rêves
des choses magnifiques des choses
étranges je te connais toi non c'était
un an avant tu savais que les esprits
errait dans ces bois ils viennent nous
voir quand on dort ils viennent dans nos
rêves tous ces trucs attrape le
cauchemar attaoui certains attrapent les
esprits maléfiques
[Musique]
quand tu t'endors essaie de penser à des
choses agréables
pose ta maman ou l'avait libéré il faut
le détruire tout de suite où les gamins
font des cauchemars il souffre de
tendance l'attend à la violence je serai
bien là qu'il agisse en eau non dieu et
tu te trouves rien mieux faire que nous
et c'est ici où son père a été tué dans
5les ou pourtant dit qu'il va
parfaitement bien
jos
au début ça chatouille un petit peu
quand il rentre en toi après il commence
à dévorer
ça suffit donne moi ça donne moi sommes
maintenant à toi il était une fois un
petit garçon qui s'applique girl et fut
cette nuit dans mon sommeil qui avait
[Musique]
le tu me rappelles toi je te promets que
je vais c'est pas juste
qu'est ce que c'est qu'est-ce-qui pas
juste elle est mort et toi à tenir
vous devez le tuer sinon c'est lui qui
vous tuera et qui me tuera mois et le
mâle n'en finira jamais de revenir
encore et encore
qui commande